[Música]
[Aplausos]
un día
llegó a la casa
yo la casa cansado no es el cansancio
físico
es lo único que se le puede descubrir
como cansancio emocional
la famosa hueva emocional y no sé qué
está pasando porque tengo un buen
trabajo soy una gran empresa gano bien
lo que sea significa eso
amo a mis clientes creo en la
importancia de mi trabajo pero algunos
checa algo
no falta
este estadísticamente comprobado que más
del 80 por ciento de los mexicanos no es
feliz en su trabajo y siendo parte en
ese momento del promedio llegó a la casa
y por millonésima ocasión pronunció una
frase ojo tengo la fortuna de estar
casado con la mejor coach del mundo y
por millán es una ocasión comentó lo
siguiente
no me siento
no me siento valorado como que
como quería un poco
y en eso ese día descubrí que hasta los
mejores coaches del mundo los puedes ser
encabronar y por millonésima ocasión
pues ya tenía hasta acá y me da un
sartenazo en la cabeza
el sartenazo en la cabeza viene en forma
de lo siguiente no le pidas a los demás
lo que no te das a ti mismo no le pidas
a los demás que te valoren si tú no te
valores primero no le digas a los demás
que te aumenten el sueldo si tú no eres
capaz de invertir en ti no le pidas a
los demás que te desarrollen si tú no
practicas nada nuevo y como auténtica
campeona mundial después de haberse
aventado ése cruzado de derecha venía un
volado de izquierda que terminó por un
nocaut fulminante el gancho de izquierda
fue la siguiente frase
no se trata de recibir se trata de dar
valor sin pedir nada a cambio es a la
fecha el mejor tipo de ventas que he
conocido y fue esto lo que me llevó a
grupo llamaría emprendimiento porque fue
lo que me llevó a hacer lo que empecé a
hacer en mi proyecto a iniciarlo como un
hobby porque yo lo que quería era entrar
este cotorreo del círculo de dar valor
el círculo de compartir el círculo de
dar sin pedir nada a cambio a ver a qué
chingados sabe eso y resulta que por
consecuencia a la fuerza la naturaleza
dios como le quiera llamar
conspira a tu favor y te da valor de
regreso yo estoy año y medio después de
haber iniciado aquel proyecto que yo vi
siendo testigo de esta frase y con eso
la mente te quiero comentar algo hay
muchos gurús allá afuera con cara
rentados que se pasean y te están
bombardeando por redes sociales con sus
millones de vistas edición de lo
siguiente es que tienes que arrojarse al
precipicio
tienes que te tienes que vender ships
quemar las naves
tienes que matar la vaca
yo estoy aquí para ofrecerte una serie
de pasos ligeramente menos sangrientos
si lo que quieres es emprender tu propio
camino número 1 identifica tu propósito
y hace que te hagan a un lado 50 mil 500
coaches en todos lados hablan tu
propósito es que tienes conocer tu
visión de vida cuál es tu sueño vamos
etcétera etcétera etcétera venga pero es
que esto es realmente importante porque
está a punto de emprender un camino del
todo rocoso y con baches y no es el todo
suave y no vamos a descansar como lo
hacías antes vas a salir de tu zona de
confort y el tema con esto es que
necesitas anclar de la fuente ilimitada
energía y eso solamente va a hacer que
conociendo tu propósito puede ser un
poco más sencillo de lo que crees se
trata de dejar de observar y observar te
dejar de escuchar y escucharte todo se
resume a conocerte a ti mismo incluso
puedes empezar con un pequeño
experimento cuál es esa actividad que
puede hacer que pasen 4 o 5 horas si no
te has parado ni al baño y se te olvidó
comer
por qué razón pudieras levantarte muy
temprano en la mañana y aún así con esa
emoción con esa sonrisa
aún así sea lo más temprano y con todas
las ganas el cansancio físico que
pudieras tener o lo haces con toda esa
pasión eso todo eso está ligado a tu
propósito número 2 aprovechar el miedo
hay dos tipos de miedos extrañado que
congela y el miedo que te impulsa actual
el miedo que te congela muchos lo
conocemos como el miedo al rechazo el
miedo al fracaso aquí vamos está que te
dice puedes cuesta no espérate está dura
la crisis mejor un trabajo un trabajo
seguro mira mejor tienes que descansar
ya trabajas mucho mira no te preocupes
zona de confort
en las ventas se le conoce como el miedo
a vender el miedo que tengan que no
entonces como como como no me da ese
miedo bueno simplemente no lo intento y
se acabó por el otro lado tienes el
miedo que te provoca actuar son esos
perros rabiosos que no puedes dejar que
te alcancen pues el de la renta puede
ser la colegiatura de tus hijos una
deuda la hipoteca cuál es eso que te
está persiguiendo y no te puede permitir
que descanses que no te va a permitir
que te rindas muchísimo se habla de las
mamás que son capaces por algún momento
de poder en un accidente de automóvil de
poder levantar el automóvil en aras de
salvar a su criatura a su hijo su hija
no pues esto es en contra de cualquier
lógica en cualquier en contra de
cualquier fuerza física como es posible
que sea capaz una mujer de levantar un
auto con tal de salvar su hijo su hija y
es fácil aquí es donde nos podemos
preguntar cuál será el miedo más
importante el miedo que tras romper la
espalda después lastimarte de forma
permanente tu cintura o el miedo a que
se muera tu hijo o hija
ese es el segundo el miedo que es
dinámico y te provoca actuar incluso en
contra de un propio miedo que te impide
hacerlo no entonces cuál es ese miedo
del cual te puedes apalancar cuál es ese
miedo cuál te puedes aprovechar para
impulsar este nuevo camino que estás a
punto de emprender dale forma de negocio
hay algunas preguntas sencillas un mini
plan de negocio si tú quieres cuál va a
ser tu oferta de valor qué problema vas
a resolver
ojo que problema vas a resolver a qué
personas les puedes ayudar dónde están
esas personas a quienes les puedes
ayudar
cuál va a ser el aspecto diferenciador
entre tu compañía y la competencia y por
último cómo vas a generar utilidades hay
todo un tip para los que tienen
competencia de precios etcétera etcétera
no estamos en el negocio del precio
estamos el negocio de las utilidades
el producto mínimo viable
el producto mismo viable con lo que ya
puede salir el tema del en del
emprendimiento es más acción que de otra
cosa más acción que de teoría en mi caso
por ejemplo yo soy de acción y después
corrección el tema del producto mínimo
vital es algo súper interesante es aquel
prototipo algo con lo que puede salir a
vender en este momento ya sea por
servicio o por producto pero es algo que
puedes poner y es de manera urgente
hacer la primer transacción tan pronto
como tengas ese primer prototipo que ya
funciona ya resuelve un problema ya le
puede ayudar a una persona a satisfacer
una necesidad de resolver un problema
insisto bueno tienes que hacer esa
transacción esa primer transacción lo
más rápido posible para que puedas
capitalizar y estar constantemente
evaluando y modificando tu producto
mínimo viable establecen metas
lo que no se mide no se puede cumplir lo
que no se mide no se puede mejorar
todos los días recibo mensajes y recibo
a gente que que que se acerca conmigo
con esta duda gerentes de ventas
empresarios que me dice gerardo como le
puedo ayudar a mis colaboradores al
equipo de ventas que cumplan con su
cuota no están cumpliendo con la cuota
llevan una mala racha de ventas que
podemos hacer
las metas más populares se miden de la
siguiente forma mensual semestral anual
vamos por la primera que lo que pasa con
las metas mensuales semana 1
de tiempo
l'aquila
semana 2
tuve tiempo no tanto tranquilo
semana 3 ya empieza un cosquilleo tal
vez aquí en el estómago de tal vez ya
tienes que empezar a mover el trasero
cuarta semana es un infierno total un
estrés total por hacerlo que en tres
semanas no querías hacer pasan las
ventas y pasa en el emprendimiento y
pasen cualquier cosa entonces mi consejo
estos empresarios sus gerentes líderes
de ventas les digo resumen los métricos
diarios cuando tú los resúmenes cuántos
resúmenes tus metas sus objetivos en
métricos diarios puedes atrapar
tendencias pues atraparte y tengo 23
días de no cumplir esta meta necesitamos
ahora sí que muy group reagruparse poder
hacer un análisis que podemos qué
cambios podemos hacer sin esperar al
estrés que te llega al final del
mes
desarrolla una comunidad
hoy por hoy tú y tu empresa eres quien
google dice que eres hoy por hoy tu
empresa eres quien facebook dice que
eres podemos ser víctimas o victimarios
de las plataformas digitales yo lo que
te quiero invitar lo que te quiero retar
es que a partir de hoy puedas
apalancarse de estas como unas
herramientas para hacer crecer tu
negocio desarrolla una comunidad en este
mundo en esta era en la era de la
información hay dos roles nada más el
del consumidor o el de proveedor el día
de hoy te quiero retar a que formes
parte del club de los proveedores
actúa como una empresa grande que lo que
hace las empresas grandes delegan tienen
outsourcing tenemos la fortuna de tener
plataformas digitales al alcance de
nuestras manos que por unos cuantos
dólares nos permiten tener un asistente
virtual un grupo de diseñadores
copyright ers mercado o logos y
productores editores todo está al
alcance de nuestro celular en este
momento en tu proyecto en tu
emprendimiento lo que menos tiempo lo
que menos tienes es tiempo recuerda que
estás haciendo todo esto mientras
trabajas
tu moneda de cambio más importante es el
tiempo actúa como las grandes empresas y
delega lo que puedas delegar
y este es el tipo de ventas que te puedo
dar más importante que pudiera a pesar
de las conferencias a pesar de un
podcast a pesar de lo que sea este es el
tipo más importante ayuda a la mayor
cantidad de personas posibles hay una
frase que me encanta de ventas que es
quieres hacer un millón de dólares ayuda
un millón de personas de eso se trata se
trata de cómo a través de tu producto tu
servicio ligado a tu propio propósito
puedes ayudar a la mayor cantidad de
personas posibles porque cuando lo ves
de esta forma
hay algo que te hace diferente a los
demás y se llama pasión se llama
propósito y el propósito y la pasión es
una ventaja competitiva
hay una modo del emprendimiento
y no tiene nada que ver con la economía
no tiene que ver con los empleos no
tiene nada que ver con nada de eso ni
siquiera con un tema político
tiene que ver con el tema de propósito
mucha mala fama una etiqueta muy fea que
se les ha puesto a la generación
millennials es que son flojos que no
saben trabajar
y realmente son la generación con mayor
información con mejor capacidad y con
mayor energía que este mundo ha visto
porque pueden ser capaces de encontrar
lo que sea al alcance de sus manos de
esta forma el problema no es que no
sepan trabajar el problema es que las
empresas de hoy la mayoría de las
empresas de hoy les ofrece algo que
ellos no están buscando lo que necesitan
es formar parte de algo importante
formar parte de algo con propósito
muchas empresas todavía no entienden eso
y solamente ofrecen algo transaccional
y por último tienes que ser tú mismo tu
mejor cliente y aquí hay dos caras de la
moneda tu mejor cliente me refiero a que
tienes que estar total y absolutamente
convencido de que tu producto sirve de
que tu producto tu servicio
cambia vidas y que tiene un impacto
positivo en tu comunidad en la vida de
las personas que lo utilizan o lo
consumen
tienes que estar tan convencido o
convencida de que seas capaz de
endeudarte con tal de consumir tu propio
producto tu servicio
y la otra cara de la moneda
dice que todos somos vendedores todos
los que estamos aquí somos vendedores
consciente o inconsciente
y hay un cliente que nos sigue a todos
lados hay un cliente que tenemos 24/7
qué discurso de ventas le das al espejo
qué presentación de ventas de ti te das
todos los días
no puedes la situación está difícil hay
mucha inseguridad mejor más adelante
yo te invito te reto
a qué ligado a tu propósito puedas
contribuir y dar valor a esta comunidad
y tal vez tal vez mediante tu
emprendimiento dejes este mundo un
poquito mejor de cómo lo encontraste
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]